we're going to color this map coloring a
map
okay now now two things I want you to
keep in mind the first thing is how many
states are there states and territories
there are one two three four five six
seven hey I actually should have drawn
that we went through that like it's much
smaller than that but you get the idea
so you've got your eight in there okay
now if I were to color this right
I could color every state and territory
differently I could write it Sam in fact
some of the maps maybe do okay but I
want us to do use we want to use as a
few colors as possible so we are trying
to eye in some fields of math this is
called optimization okay you're trying
to minimize something get less and less
than this secondly cuz if we want it to
be a map we can read right not only
doing what as few colors as possible but
we want enough such that no sort of
intersecting States or territories have
the same color
right sir oh I should've said no
adjoining maybe nothing that's touching
right we don't want them to be the same
color excuse me because you know it'll
be quite a hard map to read if you know
this is reading this is red or something
like that okay so like I said if you do
not have multiple colors like I do okay
maybe you want to like do some kind of
shady or cross hatching something so
that you can tell them apart okay what
you don't think about this how'd it go
most people have gotten over the initial
hump you should actually during the big
write some Sun better than others
and you start to put colors in now quite
a few a few of you have finished your
coloring and I've seen different numbers
of colors use I've seen someone who's
done it cause their diagram that's
perfect however I'm stirring up here it
looks very very nicely attractive which
I suppose is appropriate in this topic
but it's what what few are than eight
right we need a few the name for
instance just as an example if I were to
pick two states like say Western
Australia and Queensland they can
clearly be the same color thank clearly
right regardless of whatever else is in
between because they're not touching so
I don't I'm not I'm not concerned that
they're the same color because I can
still read nothing just might in fact
let's do that like I said I'm going to
make so I said I'm going to suggest this
can be the same color now there are
other states I can also make the same
color right give me another one
Victoria and Tasmania actually I can do
yeah that's right Victoria doesn't touch
either of these two so it's no problems
deliver as maybe he's not touching any
one poor line um okay so he's fine it
can be any color we like yeah
and then someone said AZ - good okay now
I have three states left to color right
and so far I've only used a single color
right so let's pull this out okay now
where should I start
pick a pick of state so if I make this
green okay
now automatically I can't make this
cream right no way I'm sort of locked in
but new South all can be green right cuz
it's not touching okay now I have one
stay left
just one state now can it be red no
because it borders red states can it be
green no so it must be it must be
another color unfortunately no no I mean
okay now there you go all my states are
colored okay how many colors have I used
I've used three that's interesting so
many states but so a few colors right
and you know you saw where I started you
could knock off a lot of them just with
that first color okay all right now
here's what I want you to do and he's
with your piece of paper pieces of hey
we're gonna come in - okay um
I want you to see number one okay I want
you to see if you can design a country
with States in it just like this okay
which is like Australia in that you need
three and exactly three colors to do the
map okay three colors can you do another
one that's similar so it three colors
this is this is then after that you've
got another piece of paper I want you to
see if you can do another different
country that is designed such that you
need four colors some of you have
already used four colors too close but
you can see I don't need four
now last one five colors okay three
different states maybe maybe for them
you can just turn over the piece of
paper and when you design it I want you
to give to the friend your friend next
to you
and get them to color it and see if they
can if when you get it from your friends
see if you can get in three and then
four and then in five okay so you're
gonna design three and then you're going
to get through from the person next to
you or from someone nearby okay